[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle combo je peints sur les
murs c'est mon travail
bien souvent quand je me présente de
cette manière certaines personnes voyant
mon visage je me demande si je suis
peintre en bâtiment en fait je fais du
street art il
c'est à dire que le décollage je fais
des fresques dans la rue et ça depuis
mon adolescence
ça veut dire que maintenant 90 % de mon
travail est déjà disparu c'est la nature
même de l'art urbain que d'être éphémère
alors qu'est-ce qu'on laisse derrière
soi quand on travaille dans la rue quand
on parle d'héritage on parle souvent de
ce qu'on reçoit et ceux de ce qu'on
laisse aux tiens moi dans ma famille il
n'y avait pas d'artistes en tout cas
c'est parce qu'on m'a légué comme
culture on m'a appris surtout être
curieux à mettre les choses en question
et l'amour la justice l'a en fait je ne
suis venu que par la suite je suis venu
par par l'école fait très simplement par
les livres d'histoire tous ces images
sur ces photos ces fresques ses
peintures me fascinait étant plus jeune
si bien que après dans ma des études
supérieures ma première année en fait ma
seule année au bozar mes professeurs
m'ont me pose la question et me
demandais surtout en fait tu m'expliquer
que si je ne comprenais pas une oeuvre
d'art c'est je n'avais pas les clefs de
lecture va d'une certaine manière c'est
que je manquais de culture c'était ma
faute si bien que dès que j'ai commencé
à faire mes premiers collages
j'ai voulu utiliser mes propres lectures
c'est à dire en fait la culture qui est
la mienne les images avec lesquels j'ai
grandi en fait c'est la culture ma
génération
ce que je voulais faire c'est que je
voulais me réapproprier ces images je
voulais les détourner
je me disais qu'en fait ça pouvait
donner quelque chose de différent
et puis tant pis si ça ne plaît pas aux
plus anciens mais très vite j'ai compris
que en allant dans la rue on ne pouvait
avoir trahi dans la rue avait une portée
plus symbolique ça s'est imposée à moi
très rapidement quand j'ai commencé à
travailler je me pose la question qu'est
ce que ça ce public si ce n'est avant se
passe où on se déplace on est en
mouvement
on est des piétons en réalité si bien
que lorsqu'on veut devenir acteur dans
l'espace public que catherine droit de
faire et ce qu'il ne faut pas avoir une
autorisation de la préfecture pour
manifester en france et même je vais
vous dire un petit chose c'est que l'om
est un peu bizarre pour nous les sept
artistes et pour les graffeurs nous et
pas juste interdit de dégrader un bien
public ou privé en fait ce qui nous
interdit ces deux tracés d'écrire que ce
soit la bombe à la craie si bien qu'en
fait on nous interdit de nous exprimer
alors moi quand j'allais dans la rue je
me suis dit qu'en fait je prenais la
parole et en prenant la parole je
prenais pouvoir si bien qu'en fait au
moins street art c'est devenu une sorte
de putsch
alléché d'armures et quotidien alors je
me suis dit que mon travail doit être un
peu plus engagés que je devais être
reprendre la parole vis-à-vis de ceux
qui prennent la parole tous les jours
dans ma télé dans ma radio
toutes ces personnes qui en fait vont
utiliser les symboles français
le lexique français pour nous amener à
une vision de leur de la société fait
une vision qui est la leur toutes ces
personnes qui utilisent à longueur de
journée des oxymores comme tolérance
zéro comme égalité des chances
toutes ces personnes qui vont
intervertir les ad non des mots avec des
adjectifs transformant certains
musulmans sommes certains en français de
certaines confessions pas les citer
lapsus révélateur donc les transformant
en fait en nouveau le nouveau musulmans
de france juifs de france est en fête
avec leur novlangue transforme de
société la rendant de plus en plus aux
reviennent donc toutes ces personnes
j'ai voulu pouvoir m'exprimer par
rapport à eux et prendre et prendre
aussi la parole c'est l'air un peu d'une
manière qui nous confie ce que tous les
jours mais malheureusement ça suffit pas
de devenir et de dire sa vérité pour
changer les choses
ça suffit pas de venir et de faire la
morale il faut aussi avoir une sorte de
connivence avec les gens et quoi de
mieux que l'humour
quoi de mieux que d'utiliser des images
connues de tous pour mettre un pied dans
la porte
donc je me suis dit que je pouvais
peut-être me tourner vers des images
qu'on a l'habitude de tout temps voir si
bien qu'on n'a même plus le l'esprit de
l'es2 les critiques et de les remettre
en question les images de khartoum
des images de films des images de presse
des images d'art ancien et après avoir
fait ça ce que vous voyez je me suis dit
que je pouvais essayer de de les
persuader après avait après avoir essayé
de convaincre
je vais vous donner un exemple en fait
je me suis mis à faire ce genre de
détournement
j'ai mis ko riou par mohamed ali
j'ai fait marié maître yoda
j'ai même montré le coming out de tintin
haddock et j'ai fait danser jésus sur
why m6 alors voilà après avoir fait des
choses drôles
après avoir comme j'ai dit persuadé
peut-être qu'il était temps de
convaincre
je me suis dit que peut-être il était
temps de dire quelque chose de
déplaisant
un peu comme avec vous aujourd'hui en
février 2000 cas 2015 j'ai été agressé
en fait c'était à paris dans le 2ème
arrondissement
j'étais en train de peindre une peinture
voilà je peignais le mot coexistent dans
lequel j'avais mélanger les symboles
religieux
la croix chrétienne l'étoile de david et
croissant musulman et je l'avais
accompagné d'un collage ce collage c'est
moi même en fait c'était moi avec une
barbe et djellaba grimé comme une sorte
de caricature de musulmans et les
personnes qui m'ont agressé n'ont pas
aimé ce message elle me demandait le
retirer moi j'ai laissé en fait c'était
juste après juste après les attentats
charlie hebdo
quelques jours après et moi je voulais
diffuser un message différent différent
de celui qu'on voyait tous les jours à
la télé un message qui allait vers ce
qu'on appelle le vivre ensemble un peu
plus d'amour un peu plus de tolérance
en tout cas c'est sais ce que c'est ce
que je voulais raconter mais mais ça n'a
pas empêché sa part à empêcher la dame a
pressé et
j'ai très vite reçu beaucoup de messages
de soutien
énormément de messages de partout sur
d'avalanche d'amour
si bien que ça m'a poussé ça pousse à
continuer pendant des mois
pendant des années ce travail là et
c'était une période assez particulière
en france au niveau la culture on avait
une sorte d'autocensure qui se crée chez
tout le monde
c'est à dire que des pièces de
programmes des programmes de théâtre
était déprogrammé des artistes voyez
leurs oeuvres vandalisées dans la rue
d'autres voiliers leur offre censuré par
des musées qui les avait annoncés et
c'est normal on peut comprendre qu'ils
aient eu peur de représailles ou de ou
d'attentats moi par contre j'ai continué
et continue et mettre mon message
partout partout où j'allais que ce soit
à paris ça soit à tunis ce soit même à
tel aviv
je crois qu'il ya un souci sur les
images ça marche voilà je voulais je
vais diffuser un message d'amour en fait
je voulais battre un peu contre tout
obscurantisme main qu'ils soient de
partout et je voulais continuer à
partager ça partout où j'allais mais
quand j'ai repeint un autre co existent
à evry sap a empêché de personnes à de
vouloir venir encore malgré ça je me
suis pas arrêté j'ai continué j'ai
rencontré plein de monde
j'ai rencontré des militants j'ai à
contrer des associations j'ai rencontré
des journalistes
j'ai rencontré même des politiques et
avec eux je partage est toujours mon
message je voulais partager au plus
grand nombre
certaine manière mais encore une fois
quand j'ai fait un coexistent à
sarcelles ça pas m'empêcher encore un
groupe de personnes devient m'agresser
mais j'ai continué j'ai continué je me
suis alors empressé de d'essayer de
peindre sur tous les symboles qui sont
les nôtres qui ont été un peu pris en
otage par tous les
tous les extrémismes de tout bord je
voulais me réapproprier encore une fois
pas leur laisser ne pas leur laisser
dans les mains et ça évidemment ça pas
plus
et cette peinture en fait on est
l'exemple puisque parmi tous d'autres
parmi beaucoup d'autres
elle a été vandalisé ça les a poussé un
peu à faire la même chose qu'ils ont
fait avec d'autres artistes
mais je vous raconte tout ça en fait je
raconte toutes ces choses négatives et
c'est pas c'est pas le plus important
c'est que le plus important c'est que
pendant ce temps là j'ai reçu énormément
de messages de soutien
ça n'arrêtait pas et toutes ces
personnes elle me pousse à continuer
dans ma voix un poussé à ne pas
abandonner et cette voix m'a poussé à
aller maintenant à avoir des oeuvres qui
sont exposés dans des musées
que ce soit ici à paris à l'institut du
monde arabe au musée l'immigration ou
encore dernièrement au musée d'art
moderne de münster en allemagne
si bien qu'il ya des certaines de mes
oeuvres qui sont dans des collections
muséales vous même acheté par des villes
cette voix m'a poussé aussi à être
publiées dans des livres pas seulement
des livres d'art mais aussi des livres
d'histoire d'éducation civique
si bien que des étudiants actuellement
font leurs devoirs sur le co existent
pas seulement aussi sur mon travail sur
les migrants sur la laïcité et la
personnellement moi c'est ma plus grande
fierté
je suis vraiment désolé de leur donner
plus de travail mais en tout cas moi ça
me rend heureux
je vais aussi mes collages je les ai
retrouvés dans différents médias et de
la presse dans la télé noms du web et ça
pouvait aller de n'importe quel sujet ça
pouvait être sur le vivre ensemble ça
pouvait être sûr des manifestations
travailleurs j'ai même vu un candidat à
la dernière présidentielle utiliser mes
images dans son clip de campagne
campagne officielle sans me demander de
mon autorisation
il ya eu aussi ce film coexistent qui
est sorti en décembre dernier
l'année dernière 2017 je vous en parle
pas parce que ce film s'inspire de moi
il s'inspire pas du tout de mon travail
ni de ce que je raconte en fait ce qui
m'a intéressé c'est qu'il parlait la
même chose que moi il vous voulez rire
de la même chose la même thématique est
en fait je vous raconte pas ce qu'il
s'est passé une chose incroyable à sa
sortie c'est passé absolument rien rien
aucune polémique
aucun dérapage aucun acte violent envers
le film c'est à dire que ce qui se passe
c'est deux ans auparavant quitté
dangereux tout d'un coup ils de revenu
normal et pour moi c'est ici la preuve
qu'on a fait le job qu'on avait réussi
qu'on avait pacifier un peu le débat
qu'on avait ramené les le discours à la
normale jeudi nous parce que évidemment
je suis pas le seul sur cette terre à
travailler sur ces thématiques
il ya beaucoup de personnes
indépendantes il ya latif a balisé
athènes pour ne citer qu'elles il ya
beaucoup d'associations des militants il
ya coexister et l'uejf sos racisme je
pourrais passer ma journée vous énumérez
énormément de gens qui se battent tous
les jours et qui sont vraiment
incroyables mais évidemment que je suis
pas je suis je suis pas bonne et je suis
pas idiot je sais très bien que le monde
est pas tout rose
les problème n'est pas résolu mais en
tout cas il ya une vérité qui ce qui se
présente devant moi c'est que maintenant
je sais que la rechange les gens et que
les gens eux changent le monde
alors est-ce que c'est ce que moi je
vais laisser derrière moi
est ce que c'est ce que je vais laisser
à mes enfants au vôtre est ce que quand
ils vont penser au passé
ça veut dire à notre époque quand ils
vont au cancer leur l'histoire est ce
qu'ils vont avoir des images qui vont
leur apparaît dans la tête comme la
liberté guidant le peuple de delacroix
ou guernica de picasso
peut-être même les photos cartier
bresson et peut-être j'ose espérer
certaines de mes peintures merci
[Applaudissements]